liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer frau
bundeskanzlerin
es mag sie nerven aber ich will
ausdrücklich festhalten
für die linke bleibt es inakzeptabel
dass wir im bundestag erst wieder nach
einer ministerpräsidenten runde
debattieren und nicht vorher in der
krise in der krise zeigt sich die stärke
der demokratie und ihrer institutionen
und der bundestag gehört dazu
obwohl es ganz man sie sind der
auffassung dass im großen und ganzen ist
nichts schief gelaufen
er bringt was hat ihnen den satz gesagt
sinngemäß selbst bei den toten liegen
wir gut den würde ich nochmal überprüfen
ich will festhalten dass viele menschen
in unserem land das anders sehen mit dem
schief gelaufen
sie haben auch heute wieder 0 selbst
kritik geäußert aber vergleichsweise
viel selbstgefälligkeit auch eine
bundeskanzlerin steht ein gewisses maß
ein mindestmaß an selbstkritik gut zu
gesicht meine damen und herren
bundeskanzlerin sie haben auch
vorschläge aus diesem haus von uns von
den grünen von der fdp wenig gehört und
im sommer und im herbst das land nicht
auf den corona winter entsprechend
vorbereiten wenn nur ein beispiel nennen
im herbst ist hier über ein
schutzkonzept für heime gesprochen
worden auch viele experten haben das
eingefordert und täglich sterben weiter
viele menschen in alten- und pflegeheim
weiß ich nicht geschützt werden und der
impfstoff in hessen zb gaben im januar
73 prozent derjenigen die am corona
verstorben sind aus alten und
pflegeheime und sie sagen da ist nichts
schief gelaufen das sterben in den
heimen ist vielleicht das dunkelste
kapitel der letzten jahrzehnte
und dazu gab es übrigens nie ein gipfel
nicht dass wir als opposition das alles
besser gemacht hätten darum geht es
überhaupt nicht
aber diese papst hatte
der unfehlbarkeit die ist in dieser
situation unangebracht meine damen
deshalb in einer historischen
ausnahmesituation oder das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger über das wir alle
sprechen das höchste gut ist sollten
fehler zugegeben werden und nicht
selbstgerecht vom tisch gewischt werden
und in den letzten monaten meine damen
und herren ist vieles schiefgelaufen vom
pandemie weltmeister im frühjahr sind
wir abgestiegen in den im keller europas
wir haben seit wochen seit wochen lehre
im cent würden millionen verzweifelte
bürger die stundenlang in warteschleifen
stecken und sie sagen es ist nicht
schief gelaufen beim impfen stehen wir
hinter rumänien hinter griechenland
hinter der slowakei beim werfen
wir sind selbst in der eu weit
abgeschlagen und frau bundeskanzlerin
deutschland hatte im vergangenen jahr
von juli bis dezember die
ratspräsidentschaft der eu
natürlich ist es richtig das europäisch
bestellt wurde das bestreitet doch von
uns hier niemand aber überaus fraglich
ist in der tat warum sie eine frühere
ministerin damit beauftragt haben die
schon einmal an verträgen gescheitert
ist wovon allein nach dem berater
skandal im verteidigungsministerium den
ausliegenden europa zu ermöglichen war
augenscheinlich ein fehler bemerken aber
zurückgewiesen
deutschland in deutschland wachsender
unzufriedenheit verzweiflung und auch
mut das hat sie auch nach gestern sich
geändert und das wissen sie und herr
brinkhaus hat die länder wo es nicht
funktioniert genannt aber in den usa in
großbritannien israel in vielen anderen
ländern wird in rekordtempo geimpft und
in deutschland erleben die menschen
aktuell nebeneinkünfte werke das ist die
wahrheit und sie müssen drei fragen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern beantworten
erstens warum bestellte die eu unter
deutscher ratspräsidentschaft den
impfstoff in deutschland mit viel
steuergeldern gefördert gefördert hat
vier monate später als großbritannien
und die usa waren bestellte die weru
zweitens unter deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft weniger impfdosen
von biotech und moderner als möglich
waren und warum hat es deutschland
zugelassen dass beim preis gefeilscht
worden ist 520 millionen impfdosen
wurden zunächst weniger bestellt andere
staaten haben nicht geknausert als es um
das leben ihrer bürgerinnen und bürger
gehen und drittens warum hat sich die eu
unter deutscher ratspräsidentschaft und
die bundesregierung selbst im jahr 2020
nicht um die ausweitung der
produktionskapazitäten gekümmert der
impfmuffel vergangene woche der war
faktisch ein placebo sie haben die
impfstoffentwicklung zurecht gefördert
aber die produktion bis heute
verschlafen großbritannien und die usa
agieren vergleichsweise komplett anders
und du sagen sie immer am anfang ist das
der flaschenhals ist dass der
flaschenhals
aber das ist nicht der fall in den usa
in 1,5 millionen menschen täglich
geimpft und es werden auch täglich noch
mehr die geimpft werden
die amerikaner haben eben sehr früh mit
18 milliarden worbs pete forschung
produktion und impfstoffe darein
investierten und die eu hat drei
milliarden nur darin es wird investiert
was für ein mißverhältnis europa hat
aber deutlich mehr einwohner und es ist
kein zufall dass in drei amerikanischen
bundesstaaten inzwischen mehr geimpft
worden ist als in ganz europa und wenn
sie hier zu sagen herr brinkhaus völlig
zurecht im strategie aber sorgen sie
immer dafür dass bei den hausärzten
jetzt die voraussetzung geschaffen
werden dass die impf berechtigt sind
damit die zügig agiert
20 millionen impfen die jedes jahr für
grippe das muss man aber jetzt
vorbereiten damit das mögliche meine
damen und herren will eine bemerkung
machen pandemie das weltweit ja was ist
eigentlich mit den globalen süden wann
soll der hilfen
wir haben eine sondersituation und
deswegen heben sie die patente auf es
muss global produziert und geimpft
werden patentschutz ist eine impf bremse
und eine mutation stoner kann veränderte
form zurückkommen das erleben wir gerade
meine damen und herren für kinder für
jugendliche für alleinerziehende wird
der zustand mit jedem tag unerträglicher
kinder dürfen aber nicht die verlierer
der krise sein
wieviel erziehungswissenschaftlerin und
erziehungswissenschaftler waren
eigentlich bei ihren beratungen dabei
heute eine studie aus hamburg ein
drittel der kinder haben psychische
störungen durch die pandemie
es ist nicht nur das virus das krank
macht es ist auch der umgang mit dem
virus der zunehmend schäden anrichtet
die bürgerinnen und bürger haben die
infektionszahlen mit viel
selbstdisziplin und solidarität nach
unten gebracht ja da gehört immer der
dank wie auch zu den ärzten pflegern da
kann ich mich ihnen anschließen aber sie
haben das auch im vertrauen auf die
politik gemacht und das wurde vielfach
enttäuscht
sie haben heute darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass er altmaier gestern das
schon auf die seite gebracht hat ehrlich
gesagt am 10 februar jemand die november
hilfen sind teilweise noch nicht
ausgezahlt november hilfen wir haben
februar
das ist ein skandal und fragen sie mal
unternehmer und handwerker wie stehen
geht und als auch herr altmaier sieht
keine fehler und schiebt dass auch die
länder als wenn da keine fehler sieht
dann muss er wirklich mal zum augenarzt
gehen meine damen und herren 100000
menschen bangen um ihre
selbstständigkeit und ihre
wirtschaftliche existenz warum gibt es
kein unbürokratisches selbstständigen
geld keinen unternehmerlohn den großen
helfen sich vergleichsweise
unkompliziert wie wir immer wieder sehen
und bei den kleinen warten sie
monatelang und meine damen und herren
das land treibt aktuell sozial weiter
auseinander
familien und menschen in der
grundsicherung haben sie nach dem
koalitionsausschuss jetzt 150 euro
gegeben ja das ist richtig aber ehrlich
gesagt ist natürlich viel zu wenig 12
eur 50 im monat sind das und ich will
mal dazu sagen am selben tag am selben
tag wird mit stolz verkündet dass die
ausgaben für verteidigung nach nadel
kriterien bei 53 milliarden sind was ist
denn das für eine relation und da sagen
sie noch stolz ich sage das ist wahnsinn
uns bedrohen keine fremden armeen uns
bedroht ein virus und nichts anderes
meine damen und herren und werden wir
sehen dass der eigentümer der
supermarktkette lidl sein vermögen in
der krise von 22 milliarden auf 36
milliarden dollar gesteigert hat dann
ist das auch schön wenn wir alle hier
sagen die korona helden denen müssen
gedanken bei denen es auch bei den
arbeitsbedingungen bei den löhnen viel
zu wenig passiert andere haben
milliarden zu wechseln und bei denen
wird wirklich nur gekleckert nein meine
damen und herren aktuell kommt
deutschland als ganzes eben nicht durch
die gut durch die krise ihre bilanz ist
nicht gut weder bei der pandemie
bekämpfung noch im sozialen bereich noch
bei die wirtschaftshilfen es muss
schluss sein mit selbstgerechtigkeit wir
brauchen transparenz wir brauchen
möglichst eine planbarkeit ja völlig
richtig nicht an daten aber an mehreren
werten damit zuversicht in unserem land
steigt das ist das dringliche gebot
zuversicht muss wieder wachsen meine
damen und herren
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]